[Music]
like the punchline is for everybody here
content that actually brings value to
the end-user
game over this portion is like with me
so I think this is one you need to get
selfish like you'd ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is no like you
got to go fast that's how you get [ __ ]
done that's a bigger step out this is
the television and the television is the
radio support these [ __ ] think
so my question is how do you look at how
much you should spend on the content
production side everything you're doing
on your personal brand I didn't really
touch my personal brand we're a Content
business ourselves versus working on
product generating more revenue to fuel
that piece my answer to that is as much
as possible on the content side
financially and time but not to over
judge yourself if you're not doing it
that's fine like I don't dwell but just
so everybody understands like at the end
of the day brand is what wins it always
has it always will it's how everybody
makes a decision like literally you
cannot imagine how many decisions you're
making on a daily basis solely on brand
nothing to do with sales yet everybody
so over indexes on sales it's why you
know I've been learning a lot about the
franchisee world just because the
keynote I gave and just a lot of inbound
and like when I started realizing how
much a new franchisee pays these brokers
to get somebody it speaks the same thing
instead of spending those tens of
thousands some of these companies are
select when I looked at I'm like my god
like 40% Commission 80% Commission tens
of thousands of dollars I'm like I can
send a single tweet and put 80 people
into a franchisees right now when you
build brand you build leverage you know
veiners a 200 million dollar enterprise
and we don't do new business well at all
we don't win RFPs
we're bad at it we're bad at it because
and it's not because
Andreea or me or and it's just it's not
our DNA it's just car biggest clients
just give us the business because of
brand and by the way when you do
personal brand you actually
lose 20 or 30% of the action because
some people don't like you when you
actually just build a brand that's a
logo it really gets going you know for
me I want to do personal brand and at
some level like I'm just not driven by
money enough to like always make the
financial decision over the happiness
decision but there's nothing that is
more leverageable for you than the brand
of your company or you as individuals
where people get caught as they fake it
until they make it where everybody gets
caught is they place somebody on the
internet that they're not in real life
that has been the reason I've made it so
I would tell you that this is a very
simple game of how much profit do you
want to take home at the end of the year
the reason I've always been able to
scale and get to everything is because
I've always made it at the cost of my
own personal financial impact so you can
if you're willing to make less money you
know or or you can if you realize
actually I don't like this like I'm not
into it I'm more of a product guy I'm
more of a product gal I'm more into
getting that like self-awareness is
imperative like you can't imagine how
little time I spend on Finance are legal
I mean for all I know mark you're
getting our lawyer owns this company he
just puts things in front of me and I
just sign you know like you know but
that's why you know it's funny to have
hair like coms and new business like
that's what I or HR like these are the
things I micromanage more at least have
opinions on I actually don't micromanage
but I have opinions or occasionally I'll
have a dictatorship decision but I think
you need to first be self-aware are you
not doing it because you don't like it
or it doesn't come natural or are you
doing it because of whatever financial
requirements you're looking for whether
that means you want to take money off
the table each year in bonus and do
something in your life which is amazing
I don't judge what somebody does or is
it because you're trying to flip your
company and trying to maximize EBIT uh
for a multiple which is all okay awesome
I'm building businesses in perpetuity
and I'm playing for legacy and I don't
want to buy anything in real life so
think about why
my advice is always pour it back in if
you understand those are my North Stars
but let me say this building personal or
brand for your business is the single
most important thing in business it's
the single most important thing it's
number one two three four five and six
especially as the internet continues to
commoditize everything everything will
be commoditized everything you do can be
sold cheaper different better it is your
brand that plays in the end McDonald's
sells a lot of french fries every day I
don't make the best french fries every
day matters you don't want to be in the
sales business and that's where
everybody for the most part is because
then you're just in a hamster wheel of
only as good as your last sale you want
people coming to you the only way can do
that is through brand what's amazing
about the way we can build brand now is
everybody here can do that by providing
value for the ecosystem that they're
trying to reach versus making a clever
commercial how'd you guys get here it's
a super meta answer I didn't call you I
mean cold email you matter like they
mounted um basic [ __ ] that we do wrong
it doesn't matter you're gonna want if
you want something you'll get it we
don't want to do dumb [ __ ] but but like
but dumb [ __ ] is always trumped whereas
like other people have to have
everything perfect because they have no
brand they just have the luxury of the
quick moment of a sales pitch and the
lack of friction to
Oh migrate the singular strength my
friend Tom Bell you nailed it for me I
never thought about it
singular strength I have singular is my
inability to judge myself
I mean hurt you you felt this right away
in our first meeting you
literally our first meeting how it runs
calms now for us she's like I'd like to
we changed the mission statement on our
website it was like what the coolest one
like this is maybe the most important
thing that people it was a 38 second
meeting like okay I was dying to think
about what was going through her mind
those are like seven-month processes and
other companies because you come from a
world which is most of the world where
that literally people would have seven
hour meetings about one adjective it's
like your first week in a company you're
talking to like the over-indexing face
and founder of the company like it's a
complete reversal of what one would
think but it's because most things don't
matter once you establish a brand I
really think you should lean into it I
think it will help your business but it
takes time and I think the biggest thing
for a lot of you novice I'm giving
answered that it helps a lot of you as I
keep doing this the intent of the
content is imperative the singular
reason we win and I win is because not a
single piece of content I ever put out
has any intent to sell sneakers wine for
DS or vaynermedia not interested and
people feel it
what's that you know people call
[ __ ] radars but we're animals right
it's like a bat can sense things a dog
can sense things like we inherently have
been sold to for so long at this point
that it's of course you can be tricked
for a second because usually you're the
kind of person that wants to dream and
not put in the work the reason diet
pills and quick rich schemes work is
because people don't want to put in the
work you want to look like Nick do eat
well and work out every day
take out your shirt Nick but you know
what I mean like it's crazy there's a
trillion dollar health and fitness
industry and the math is as basic as
[ __ ] eat well workout sleep but we don't
want that we want to eat [ __ ]
cheeseburgers and [ __ ] potato chips
and get the results and that's how I
think about business this answer is a
hundred percent right we live in a world
where there's so much supply of
everything we do and it will continue to
grow because with what I understood 15
years ago was the internet was gonna be
the middle and everything was gonna be
commoditized and the only thing that
wasn't gonna be commoditized was brand
and then the ability to execute a
product that was at least within the
circumference of the competitive set but
this ideology of like we have the best
product no you don't you think you do
just like everybody thinks their kids
are the cutest did America say that
you're Miss America you know so that's
how I think about stuff how do you look
towards growing you have to be live off
of memberships and
in a very competitive tight space great
like they want me to move in into a
place where there's six other places
around the corner yeah I mean look and
it's fun to have something franchise
wars in the building like this has
become such an intriguing space for me
first of all what's really interesting
is when you're a franchisee there's a
I'm trying to calibrate in my mind this
half pregnant entrepreneurship DNA and
it's not a negative I hear you know what
I'm actually never gonna say half
pregnant again
I'm not kidding because it because
there's an I use it as an cuz I love
entrepreneur like it's a very
interesting idea where you're in between
employee and entrepreneur like that's
why you signed up for it like like to me
the thought of being at the mercy of the
franchisor is devastating I don't even
have a board I don't have investors like
I don't know what to do because if I
think this is right like this is why I
hated school so I hate anything that
contains me right
like even even like comms I'm like eh I
hope you know what you're signing up for
like you'll tell me but like I have no
idea what's gonna come out of my mouth
you know like I think that's I think
look first of all anything the
franchisor wants you have to be
empathetic this is not a negative it's
in their best interest and that's fine
that's amazing that's business but you
have to a that'd be the first thing I
would calibrate if you're my brother be
like okay let's first understand that
they want you to do that because they
want you to do that
there's nothing to do with you you're a
commodity even though like it's just the
truth it's okay I think that's not a
negative that's number one and number
two what are you able to do that
distinguishes yourself that still stays
within the lines of the franchise ORS
rules I don't know enough about
CrossFit's rules every franchisor has
different rules of like how hardcore how
loosey-goosey
they all run date but I would have
thank you for training yeah I mean sure
but I'm also working on rebranding
obviously so that we have more
flexibility and experiences we can
create and they allow that
okay great little do the Department is
username this we've really haver
username and it's a marketing agreement
yeah it's license not yeah literally
yeah I mean I think that um I think that
if you're talking about there's two
separate conversations here one is the
location right is just a classic supply
and demand conversation is the rent
worth the natural foot traffic you can
or the way I now think about it which is
not 1987 anymore where you just get the
traffic because there's a Whole Foods or
a mall or what-have-you
it's how much do I like the two mile
radius of Facebook and Instagram ads
against it that's how I think about it
now I think that's a really what I would
do
Tim Ferriss did something super smart
when he did the 4-hour workweek I mean I
heard about it like 13 years ago and to
this day I still think about it because
I didn't do it I wish I at some level
it's so smart and I do it with my
content I'm doing something incredibly
interesting lately with my content we
call it the Machine I'm running the same
video on Instagram with seven different
thumbnails and titles seeing which one /
indexes and then then I'm posting it
organically on my page and if they've
done much better I think one thing you
could do is almost run an ad on Facebook
and Instagram on a fake gym that doesn't
exist and say coming soon and just
seeing what people react to and be like
and just getting a sense of like I would
almost run a fake gym with maybe another
popular brand whether it's Equinox or
berries or you know whatever or in you
know orange theory or whatever and run
it on like 15 different like like mile
radius or like if you have four options
of locations and just seeing where
there's more demand I mean for a
thousand bucks you can get a read on if
there's more demand or not
from operation so things like when did
you guess like did you get a chief
operating officer what kind of works but
also what didn't work and kinda why I
suppose what um it's great question so I
always over hire always because I'm
anticipating growth and that's how you
grow you know well you'd like to think
that you're getting the clock you know
but yes to your point like I was like
you seem nice you're hired
like that was like literally how it went
for like the first 300 people because I
was willing to fire and and and I don't
like the fire I'm kind of like I'll turn
this bad boy around like that kind of
DNA so it was a really interesting like
double play on my side which is I hired
I talked about hiring fast and a firing
faster but I also don't love that firing
because I was so into being operational
and trying to fix in parallel I think a
lot of this comes down to knowing
yourself first of all so I'll give you a
very good piece of advice I genuinely
believe that I've seen this everywhere
hiring around you on the things that you
don't want to be doing is unbelievably
powerful I couldn't be more bullish on
it if all of you right now just truly
take a step back and say what do I do
every day that I don't want to be doing
and hire for that I couldn't be more the
reason the CEO has never worked for me
not my dad not my brother
not James Orsini is because I'm an
operator and I love it
and I'm willing to leave money on the
table because I know from a CEO I could
probably generate more top of the funnel
business but I love the challenge of
operating it's the game I like it
I'll Rick should be there or Susan
should take that account or will create
this prime of operating I'm good at it
that's why we're not Boehner below like
you know when you hunt you got to be
able to farm it and when you know how to
operate you know that's where most
entrepreneurs lose they can get the
business but sheer he can't operate it
right so I would highly recommend hiring
around you so if you're thinking about
CEO Oh are you just so overwhelmed or
are you trying to be more physically out
there but then if you're trying to be
physically out there look nothing
excites me more for b2b businesses today
then running content ads on LinkedIn
against the employees of the people you
know you're trying to reach like your
business is so uh dude as somebody who's
been in b2c and b2b
BB's easier like when you know who
you're trying to reach it's easier I
don't know who the [ __ ] drinks wine or
wear sneakers like but when you know
that literally the companies you're
trying to reach you can do run ads right
now against employees of that on
LinkedIn and all you have to do is make
content that is valuable to them instead
of saying sign up now instead of an
infomercial make a b2b magazine could be
even not even about your own product
like we go to speak so the reason I'm
here is because this big conference
coming up happens every year American
Association conference we have a twenty
by thirty booth we're taking a video
team with us but we're going to the
second you know obviously you know
enough about me to to know this the
second everybody here can be the voice
of the industry and bringing value to
everybody in the funnel the quicker they
win it's what I learned with Wine
Library TV I started that to do QVC and
with in Episode one within the episode
intuitively I needed to become the Wine
Spectator not QVC and it changed the
course of my life and I've done it ever
since
guys there are hundreds of agencies that
literally just watch my content and get
clients that we're trying to get with
the same words I probably think about
what's going like how much I believe in
it it's coming out of my own short-term
pockets I'm really giving my best [ __ ]
but yeah I mean but think about how
interesting that is like right like it's
really it's a really like it's kind of
not that I'm knowledgeable enough about
the Bible but like I get it thrown at me
it's like quite biblical it's like just
like it's truly that so like you you're
the greatest thing you could do at this
DC conference besides be successful and
do your thing is to listen to the
problems that they're all facing and put
out
content that addresses it or makes fun
of it like you couldn't have met I the
amount of two minute videos made that is
like a skit by comedians that make fun
of library culture is zero every single
[ __ ] person in the industry would
share a video that was funny about that
11 truths in your business you know what
I mean like the cliche [ __ ] like the
Dewey Decimal System [ __ ] yeah like that
like you should like you know like if
you guys did a Dewey thing if you like
dug up Dewey like the punchline is for
everybody here content that actually
brings value to the end user game over
yeah if you didn't back to CrossFit I
mean the big cliche thing I hear all the
time is like people get hurt if you just
put out a content series and that might
struggle with corpora and I have empathy
for that but if the content series in
theory was just like how not to get hurt
and like just deep knowledge on like the
cliche 44 reasons why people do you get
over a competitive you lose your form I
don't know what the [ __ ] I I believe in
that [ __ ]
I believe I put out so much content with
the hope that nobody ever hires us I'm
not kidding cuz enough people will and
that's how you build brand and sentiment
and like carmine like a whole lot of
other things plus there's one thing that
I always have which is I know that I'm
always gonna be good at emerging trends
I'm not scared to give away all my
social media advice because I know I'm
gonna be great a voice and AR and
machine learning and blockchain and like
it's I'm the same thing just you know
you're welcome
yep the first one is where I get mixed
up a lot is that we have two audiences
right so we're selling franchises to
$1,000,000 yep yep yep yep yep yep
so creating or how to differentiate our
company to these different audiences and
then the second piece is you know we've
been I think one thing you can do is the
logo could focus on the end user
dressers and then the humans whether you
or somebody else could focus on the
franchisees you see where I'm going
that's a first of all you or somebody
and the logo the company should have
separate accounts there's a banner media
account there's Gary B there's Wine
Library right so if you think about the
nature of it the the brand can really
focus on the end and you can focus on
the b2b part with occasional reference
to the end look I'll be honest with you
I'm also extremely comfortable with the
account doing both some people may find
it intriguing on the backend business
stuff you know it's not the end of the
world most of this stuff is not about
organic anyway it's about paid
amplification so but I think there's a
natural for you guys to have a human
face for the media yes we've been
creating content putting it out there
with very little great but like how do
you set the benchmarks for your team to
hold them accountable though how do you
know when to fire like you know if I say
hey our socials are digital states now
like I write business results and we're
doing good but I don't think we're not
gonna now to the park with me so fire
yeah there's no bench but like that's an
owner that's a she or he decision what
you're learn is you know it's like
breaking up with a boyfriend and then
thinking two boyfriends down the line
like was I wrong about Rick because he's
been a lot better than Stan and John
maybe I [ __ ] up that happens but
that's the true answer right to me it's
like are you happy with your business
results from the thing and if you're not
business results not how many likes or
shares or followers business results
right and if
not that's attributable to that you
break up with Rick and you just hope
that that was right yeah I haven't seen
anyone as well trying to get the 1
million dollar people into the funnel or
as well on the end-user ok million
dollar investment versus you know like a
crossfader a fitness you know the
owner/operator models of a hundred two
hundred thousand to invest are pretty
easy organically but that million dollar
investor it's been a little harder to
tap into organically it makes sense
because I think to get that person you
need to be making a show about the whole
concept of franchisees not about your
specific content right you see where I'm
going like you need to become the back
of ink magazine and you know like you
know what I mean but I mean but but like
you need to become ink yeah like this is
where I keep going into like that like
you need to interview like 365 days a
year somebody who successfully run a
franchise to inspire the people to
listen to that to then get into the
potential funnel of considering you
correct no it's not
and so you make that and you run that on
LinkedIn right and then on Instagram you
see what I mean mine is stay with the
brand move on to
grand ideas so we have a brand that it's
called Cebu it's our private label here
care it does have its own website it has
no brand awareness we have links from
that platform on to our other salon
sites so we do a little business online
and a little bit more now that you know
everybody understands what a CTA is an
email community but but the issue is
could we create something bigger and
better that actually solves to a bigger
purpose not just selling cebu but it
allows any brand to have a bigger site
to be able to launch their brands as
long as you as you long as you
understand how big of an ambition the
sentence that just came out of your
mouth is what you just said in that
sentence is usually a 50 million two
hundred million dollar funded startup
with deep two-way marketplace DNA the
answers you could but there's you know
people sometimes ask me hey Gary God you
were so early at all these tech
companies this is not like why don't you
have an app why don't you have a company
I'm like because I don't want to because
I don't think it's my strengths I don't
think I'm the founder of uber or
Facebook or Twitter like you're you're
also talking about at a time where
Shopify and Amazon are gonna grow at
scale so for you to create a third-party
marketplace like an infrastructure to be
a wordpress e-commerce imagine you're
going into shark territory which you
could win within a small niche i but you
have to make sure that you guys have the
DNA to actually like as long as you like
notice I'm jumping in because I want to
make sure you realize that that's not
like everything so far has been like a
pass away comment like that is a huge
like meaning not to undermine it's like
it's doable
yours is doable if you're gonna but
you're gonna build a billion-dollar
business that like that's like a real
big thing and I think people throw
around this theory very nonchalantly in
the business world every day I get a oh
we're gonna be a marketplace I'm like
there's like six marketplaces
like you know it's like like yahoo lost
being a marketplace like you know like
so yes i just want to make sure that you
understand like I'm giving you a
reaction to make sure you understand how
grand that is I believe you I'm sure at
this time when it's never gonna be
easier or less friction to do short term
sales through the Shopify and Amazon
ecosystem it's not about like it's not
the macro thesis it's the thesis at this
moment in the emergence of those two
specific platforms that gives me just
pause to like think about it but go
ahead speak to me about that when you
said I just want to make sure I'm
following along you mean how relevant
that one brand will be yeah so look I
mean it's it's not a very complicated
thing to your point you just have to
understand if you're looking to become
you know a platform or a product are you
gonna be smart water are you gonna be
it's not Walmart but it's a QVC right
they're just two very different things I
will say this I believe that we're
walking it's ironic I'm gonna take a
little bit of a different stance I think
we're walking into the golden era of the
capability of direct to consumer brands
at scale you're gonna be competing but
the opportunity to have the leverage I
mean think about the nature of being a
product you were always at the mercy of
your distribution you're not going to be
and so that's exciting it's now how good
is the product and how good are you at
building a brand around a product versus
how good are you at building a platform
and building a brand about the platform
I think that becomes the debate but I
wouldn't run away from being a brand
because a lot more brands are coming I
would try to see I see the positive in
DTC more so than a negative I really do
because because the ability to compete
against everybody else's DTC
is I think more of a fair fight than
competing with the hope that Sephora
carries you there was major toll booths
that kept all the margin the retailers
have won the leverage game over the last
decade so I think that's the question I
wouldn't I'm excited about DTC I just
think you have to be the best olive oil
you know the phrase you have to be a top
I think the long tail of DTC is more
fruitful than a long tail of marketplace
see what I'm going that's my point of
view on it and I'm spending a lot of
time in that world a lot I think at
least for us we've got 10% of our sales
we've got a 500 million sales 10% comes
a product from service right the 10%
more profitable better margin for us we
have a Schneider own haircut recom we
tried to have we build that name and the
thought was do you build a different
site that allows you to attract more
eyeballs to it to sell our product off
of versus hair better calm or you could
just what is the brain called suck what
do what about sick about building we do
that that's correct but we so our
concern is the 10% we sell right now you
can buy anymore Amazon you can buy from
website or Paul Mitchell you can go to
Amazon buy our concern is are going to
lose that 10% because you're gonna lose
it if you're not buckle about it but if
your site has an added layer of value
like a club that creates content or
access I think you should immediately
start creating a weekly monthly yearly
special SKU only available in your world
so like if you're formulating new
products you know one things I'm trying
to push a lot of my CPG brands is to
create a super premium version it's like
I'm literally trying to sell like a
hundred dollar ketchup that only comes
out during the holidays you can only buy
em they're calm so I think what's
amazing is I think this is fun my
natural DNA is always to look at the
offense of
scenario versus the defense your
defensive point of view is absolutely
correct there's far less friction to buy
from Amazon when you're buying your
deodorant and you're you know peaches
and then throw yours in but you actually
[ __ ] own the product so your ability
to create a club so if you bind yourself
you're in the club and I have no idea
what you want to add on to that because
you have no more time and I'm trying to
remember so you got this product then
you have salons right right and then you
have your own salons of this product but
the salons are yours
I mean look in theory you could tell the
end consumer that they get a 5 percent
discount on their salon work if they buy
the product on your site you've all the
advantages I'm a big fan of [ __ ] the
Amazon before it [ __ ] you that's what I
do with Facebook Facebook didn't [ __ ] me
and was like Facebook I built myself off
of it you have the leverage you can use
people you can use Amazon to get people
into your ecosystem and then remark it
to them as the brand by printing
something on the back of the [ __ ]
bottle that says come join club see
bootleg it like so I think it's a
concept of I don't think it's as black
and white as the convenience of the lack
of friction of shipping or cost I think
it's what are you gonna do to the
product and what are you gonna layer as
bells and whistles added value that
forces everybody I actually genuinely
believe that the smartest brands are
gonna [ __ ] Amazon not the other way
around if they're very thoughtful to
some of the stuff I just refer to when
you build an added value around buying
it from you at the same price you win
now you can use Amazon as your gateway
drug to acquisition that's what I would
do
other question I has is we're gonna talk
later on again about culture yes we have
a very strong intentional culture
founded business by Dennis Ratner and
he's really created that culture which
we've got a lot of tenuring in our
business but we're projecting it out
over the next 10 15 20 years from a
legacy perspective and how do we keep
that culture and that we actually make
it stronger so any recommendations on
how you believe culture here for example
what you're trying to do a great legacy
and what you'd recommend you know you've
already kind of won if even if there's
ninety eight percent let alone one
hundred percent truth behind your
statement you've already won the
ambition for legacy already changes
behavior I think this is a big game of
firing I think the biggest challenge for
people that look like me and sounds like
what you guys have is do you have the
stomach for short-term financial pain by
firing the most productive but people
that don't actually bring value to the
culture it's a very simple game of like
do you live your truth it's really easy
to maintain culture choose culture over
money I really believe it I live it I
watch it I seen in companies that I push
it into if they're an investment of mine
I really think it's you know it's scary
when something like that is so simple
but it's um it's like religion do you
follow it or don't you like and where
you choose to bend becomes the variable
of how good the culture is but culture
is made up of the humans that are in it
at the time you know and like Wenders
lore like founder Rick Thompson or Susan
Magoo she always whoever's the executive
of running that you know whoever runs
vaynermedia when I go and buy smart
water to become a CEO and that's what's
gonna happen the next chapter this
company is I'm gonna buy something when
the world melts and when I go run
Mountain Dew or stickers or Puma or
whatever the [ __ ] I buy I'm gonna be at
the mercy of her or his capability to
uphold what I believed in and so I think
you make it clear that's why you know
you know it's funny to think about
America this way right
like how we interpret the Bill of Rights
or the Constitution becomes obviously
very intriguing that's what we
becomes our culture but having it is
already the starting point but I think
it's a one I believe culture is one big
game of do you have the ability to fire
the most productive the worst person I
really believe in that yeah but the way
I think I get there is by that
in-between move I really do I really
think the reason I built Boehner and the
reason it's built this way and unique in
its way is I think I've built something
that no like if I ran if I truly bought
smart water tomorrow like it would be a
much bigger company after four years
based on all the things we've done so
I'd like to get back to the concept we
were talking about that company brand
versus personal right now our social
media content is kind of focusing on
both we've got our our company brand
that I focus on probably more than our
ease personal brand and it really is the
brand of the company makes sense so my
question is my time is limited I only
have so much to put into it which one
makes more sense to put more time into
which one is doing better from your
perspective are you doing it yourself on
your own page at all or whatever you
guys so yeah you know what what is
always the word I mean what Harry it was
like I'm sure this fun to have her in a
room like when you look when you're in
our industry as she is and you look at
Vayner from the outside people believe
the vulnerability is it's so much about
me and not enough about Vayner and
there's real truth to that if you're an
executive at SmartWater you're like am I
getting a company is it Gary like these
are the things you need to think about
at the same token when you kind of start
peeling away and you start realizing
this is a company that doesn't have to
win business through RFPs and you think
about all the dollars you start having a
really you have a more complicated to be
you know for me for example this is this
why I'm bringing this up the thing I'm
probably most proud of in the ten years
that I've run this company and built
this company is my ability to trick the
market
big it is my biggest fear was if anybody
in the big boy and girl world of
advertising understood how big what I
was building was going to be that they
were gonna focus on it and you know I'd
never competed against multi-billion
dollar international companies starting
from zero that's that's a challenge
because if one really understood me they
could just throw money at it like if
literally if I was the competitor of
vaynermedia five years ago I would have
literally emailed every single person on
LinkedIn that worked here and said
what's your salary I will pay three
times more and it would have been the
right business decision so I've
purposely not built vaynermedia's brand
because I needed the market my
competitors to underestimate it and
continue to think it's Gary and a bunch
of interns like it's who is this
charlatan and like this can't be real
that was our advantage from the outside
it's too much about me right but what
nobody knew from the inside is I have no
clients I've built a scalable company
you know building up Gary you would
think oh [ __ ] every clients gonna want
Gary I don't talk to any of them so I
was able to successfully create me as a
top of funnel awareness but then when it
became a real meeting she or he on the
other side the CMO knew right away I'm
not your account person you can be I can
be in the backbone business we can have
lunch once a year but I'm the CEO and
executive this I mean I don't service
your account you're buying vaynermedia
you're not buying Gary that comes down
to how he's running his business right
now where you guys are at scale right so
I guess those are the questions are you
servicing the business is it a
vulnerability right now is it small
enough where we can keep leaning into
what is actually working do you do a
good job once the customer comes into
the funnel to realize it's not him or is
it still him at this point which is
super fine too that's the right formula
for that does that make sense so to the
extent just go that one
further to the extent that it isn't me
doing the servicing where does that fall
into it is not you doing the servicing
okay that's very clear early in the
funnel like the conversation happens
right it's not gonna be but I still do
close almost all I get that and so did I
um then I'd probably still I would say
this if you are fortunate enough to have
a face that has all the right
personality traits I'm sure you know
Harry it's gonna continue for like I'm
not looking to suppress my people into
the press I just don't want anybody know
who the [ __ ] we are like if they think
they're like like there's strategy to it
so like I think if you still have all
the right characteristics I think if
you're fortunate to have a founder if
she or he has good characteristics and
it's not about ego and insecurity and
all those weird things then you then you
ride that personal brand because it
converts better a human face converts
better than a logo often the struggle is
also his time because he's the CEO and
he's doing all these other things his
time is extremely limited that's why I
created document not create yeah you can
bounce the riff on that or where we show
a little bit there is sort of in the b2b
world right so so we're small company
but you know what over 40 people don't
be to be worlds some interesting
parallels like our markets as we're
looking for companies headquartered very
nearby is a limited market right there's
may be like a thousand companies that
could potentially be our clients lovely
so we engage there but the people that
we connect to are generally CFOs and
CEOs who care very little about the
detail of how we execute but care a lot
about the outcomes that they get so we I
find that we struggle or I struggle to
see the document versus create when I
felt a lot of the documentation is a
super interesting to them necessarily
makes a ton of sense so to that point I
agree with you I don't think you should
document create which is why we created
the model around the podcast or the show
there's two ways to go and I think when
you start inviting them I mean so you're
saying it's literally just like nothing
excites me more and there's a couple
here than to having a regional business
to do a show around because then you get
to host a party you I mean literally
literally you guys should literally have
every
Sleater CEO and CFO on your show once
you host a party you win like you know
I've send a lot and maybe you've caught
on under my content like I call this the
high school party roll like if you're
the kid in high school who's lucky
enough that your parents travel on
weekends and you're like a c-level
popular kid
the second you throw the junior year
party at your house you go from Osito an
a-minus in popularity because you're
letting the a-pluses make out at your
house so where do we figure out how to
get that what that good is like do a
show where you interview businesses in
the Hartford area literally once you
establish some macro show like whether
you call it you know New England this or
Harford that create a macro framework
for it and now you're emailing literally
the people you want to do business with
saying we're intrigued by your
leadership we'd love to have you on the
show
versus emailing them saying we want your
business
scale it's even better like they don't
get any [ __ ] love like what even what
[ __ ] podcast wants them on their show
nobody know though really this is really
quite crazy I know you know it you're
feeling and intuitively like imagine a
world you know this played out extremely
for me real quick just to bounce around
a little bit on the pure Wow and and
1:37 side we have podcasts we just
launched the show called the CMO podcast
I got Jim Stangl who's like the former
CEO of Procter & Gamble he's like the
legendary CMO to all the current CMOS
because Proctor was Proctor he's the
host and literally the CMO so the
biggest companies in the world are
literally coming through our door every
day to be on a show imagine an hour you
will get everybody to say yes that
you've been dying to have a conversation
with them out of business if you say
come to my office and sit with me for an
hour and I'm gonna interview you about
your leadership your business your thing
they're literally walking into your
[ __ ] company and if you really have
the discipline to not sell and say
nothing nothing inevitably she's gonna
be on the way out or he's on the way out
gonna say what do you guys do here I
don't know oh really
actually I [ __ ] hate my people want
you to call it
to put you in touch with Rick Thompson
who runs our by the way there's nothing
easier than to be a host of a podcast
you asked eight basic questions how did
you get into this it's super crazy huh I
know it's super obvious and what's scary
about super obvious is how well it works
back to what I think about all the times
the reason I put out everything is I do
not believe my ideas even though a lot
of times they're early and well thought
out historically are my special sauce my
execution is my special sauce right of
course Lisa to unions like that so you
know how did you scale the business so
quickly like so one of the biggest
challenges that we have right is we've
almost we've been fairly we've been
successful so we you know our marketing
strategy we're doing a lot more digital
now but it's been a lot of we call it
one-to-many so you know they'll buff me
to go like to that can I get CPA so she
should do a lot of just educational
content right zeros all of them think
about how much if you film that and put
on link down so now the challenge we
have is like we're almost over selling
the capacity right and it's not like
McDonald's I just get a bigger fry later
and I generate more fries right the
again in human capital head is it is it
showering people over think hiring just
hire it sounds scary I'm gonna hire a
clown she or he's gonna suck and I'm
gonna lose the client I'm like but you
wouldn't have the client and when you're
willing to bleed if your ambitions high
I always feel like I'm able to expects
no but notice how my analogy wasn't the
money
it was the clients I think you're coming
from a good I think most people come
from a good place
like to breaking the brand you know
we've got we've so much good street cred
there's a huge fear of like [ __ ] up
that Claro everything's fixable yeah
give them the money back
like like money's not actually the thing
for me like I'm never scared cuz
everything's fixable I'll give you a
free service I'll [ __ ] let your son
intern here I'll do whatever the [ __ ] it
bit like everything's fixable if you
have that it this is why I talk so much
about intent
this is why talk about lack of fear plus
the biggest mistake a lot of people make
is they make a call for the other person
likes about alternatives like if the
clients happy the clients happy
regardless of what your subjective of
like are quite it's hiring I don't
overthink hiring I try my best I hire
people have so much ego in hiring it's
just this underlining like insecurity to
be wrong I love when I'm wrong guys I
mean this like you don't know me well
enough to like this is the truth like
there's a weird part of me I don't know
if it's like it's a probably a very
flawed like sick part I get excited
sometimes when I hire a very senior
person and like a week later like nope
and I know that for the next 18 months
because you know like right like right
18 months and that's like c-suite where
like you just can't scare everybody that
you're just [ __ ] changing it like
your underwear you know what I mean but
like you know what that's happened to me
twice a weekend I like good bump it up
and then all the extra work I have to
put in to disguise that and like manage
it and manage you know then four months
later the smartest people start saying
wait a minute I think this person sucks
and you got to manage that and then like
9 months later when the next level of
smart people like I think this person
side they're like you gotta like the
game lack of [ __ ] fear and more
importantly like no business than yeah
firing and listen I'm the worst I'm a
bleeding heart like you would not
imagine yes you talk about sort of like
you know what if you can't do it just
[ __ ] just overpay them out so we're
just like letting somebody go right now
that's that's the horrible like she's
got a bad situation she's only been once
I was it just give her six months
severance like whatever I do it's gonna
make a great dude at the end of the day
it's not about money out here it's about
like feeling good and happy and like it
like i understand that my CFO is not
happy with me but that's what i need i
[ __ ] fire people give me a huge
severance and then I pay them on the
side for two months I mean so much weird
[ __ ] I'm always like I always think like
man if somebody investigated me they'd
be like all yours the [ __ ] silver
bullet
why is he paying Rick on the side
I'm nice like it's like super weird but
like it's really like like nobody would
ever believe me like if you played that
on like 60 minutes of somebody trying to
get me they'd be like impossible is it
literally just your DNA there's some
like mental pneumonic this is crazy kind
of question but it's like you know I
mean you because we have sort of similar
family backgrounds actually you know
like Eastern European Jew like yeah
right and like so you know we just first
of all beat up education education
education so like when I went on Affleck
the lawyer tracked my parents are like
oh my god what's happening you know I
got lucky that's where I got really
blessed and I feel a huge sense of like
guilt and gratitude I can't believe my
mom let me get away with these and apps
what everybody else was like you're
going to [ __ ] Harvard like I got
really hit the lotto on that one but
that perfection is almost like not mine
not mine that's where I'm trying to
create clarity like I it's why I'm so
confident all that happened in my life
was everybody said I was losing except
my mom so think about that you've won it
like that's actually the dream sentence
like the dream scenario for
disproportionate confidence is the world
tells you you [ __ ] suck but your mom
tells you you're the best
and she's also smart enough to not
create deletion so when you go over for
in Little League
it wasn't the sons fault in your eye or
like your coaches it's you suck so it's
accountability but she [ __ ] crushed
it like I am a complete byproduct of and
not only that I have been hot on my
mom's like stuff lately my dad saved my
ass big because what I was also though
by being such a good storyteller was I
was completely full of [ __ ] when I was
14 I would say anything to sell anything
I lied out of my mouth 24 hours a day
and that's who I would have become and
that's what a lot of people think I am
at first because of my showmanship but
he corrected me because I got lucky
again that my dad is my dad thinks if
you embellished to him once embellish
there were 19 people at the party he's
like there were eight and that's it
three strikes you're out I'm not your
friend literally like I don't know a
single more extreme version of somebody
who's more uncomfortable with
exaggeration let alone lying that my dad
which over a course of four or five
years of my teenage years scared the
[ __ ] out of me
because it started with like dad I still
98 bottles he's like you sold six and
then six became from 98 to 44 to 13 to 6
and that got you know I got I'm very
aware of how this all happened
and then it's like it was reversed and
my dad was first parenting me and my mom
I would've been a complete nightmare
I've been insecure and full of [ __ ] like
like like so like I'm quite grateful
so anyway I'm sorry but I wanted to
create that clarity that is important
for you to know that part though
and I think a lot of what you're hearing
manifests from that but I host the party
and let's talk more because you got
three seats here like for sure so and
then you get excited and we start to
hear like yeah because geographically
gets into branding that I get excited
about like to me I wish like just cuz I
know how big I can make something cuz
I'm an operator I'm like man if I had
the New England business podcast it's
game over
give me one year yeah but like you know
like yeah that that is audacity that's
that's ego I never think anything I
think I suck I'm being dead serious I'm
confident but like I genuinely wake up
this morning and be like no like like I
could suck for the next year make a ton
of bad decisions and literally
everything I've done is wiped you know I
believe that business is unforgiving
compared to sports on this one in sports
Muhammad Ali can lose to Trevor Berbick
in his last fight we don't know that I
know that cuz I'm a boxing nerd you
don't know that right business is
different when you lose I mean everyone
then wipes out what you've done well
what's that yeah you know what I mean
like like the narrative can change very
quickly we [ __ ] on Woolworths it was the
dominant retailer in this country for a
hundred [ __ ] years but on that on
that journey right like so said not just
saying the audacity of expecting why
doesn't happen faster but there's got to
be something to know you're on the right
track right is it just the muffler no no
the market speaks your business I knew I
was on the right track because the first
two years when I was half pregnant on
vaynermedia we did three million in
revenue in the first year I ran it we
went from three to fourteen that was
very obvious and 14 to 27 like business
results and that was all based on what
larger clients bigger fees there's a lot
of there's a lot of things I'm good at
and the core thing I'm good at is a mix
of the followings I tend to sell
something that most people don't see at
first it ends up being right a lot of
times which creates the back end but at
the time I'm extremely good at selling
in the short term there was no brand
twitter I had a lot of followers so
there was a little something but what
I'm really good at is wasting no time on
selling two of the unsellable like one
of the reasons I'm fascinated by
franchise to become a franchise order
and I'm like what I do is because I
would be incredible again in franchisees
for a couple reasons one I'm just a lot
of entrepreneurs look up to me and like
so that would be good probably but after
I filled the bucket let's like empathy
okay I've sold my two million dollars
worth of wine now I've got another 4
million to sell now it's work in that
part
I just don't [ __ ] waste time like I
go to a new business pitch back to the
same way I know somebody I [ __ ] up on
I go to a new business pitch it's
scheduled for an hour
I sometimes bounce after 30 because I
decided it's over three minutes in I'm
like she has no interest in me and I
don't have ego to be like to convince
her I'll give it my best at-bat and
hopefully he or she will like it but I
think the reason I was able to grow so
quickly is I'm very good at selling and
focusing on people that will actually
buy ok get enough people interest in
I don't think I think it's funny back to
like what you said like I never think I
deserve anything period and look
vaynermedia is the only company run by
somebody who actually has success and
doing the work that they do like in the
whole [ __ ] ad world like I laugh when
people think I'm Gary Vee and don't
realize I'm running this company like
like you're doing social media work with
an agency that was built to make
television commercials I'm like the
[ __ ] poster child of the whole game
you know and yet we don't get business
from people all the time but I think if
you host a party and you go if you
create the right packaging and then the
right merchandising of that packaging
it's off to the races
I heard 50 kids who a new idea what the
[ __ ] they were doing just from where you
mean employees are employees at the time
I had a big enough Twitter my brother
brought like six of his friends from
high school in college I mean it was a
[ __ ] rat we didn't have any agency
people so at the level you're at now the
content will retreat
yeah run that's good run you should run
you run your podcast against employees
of your competitors that you want to
hire you have to do a lot more paid when
or when organic this for everybody when
organic went away from Facebook and
everybody got their anger and like [ __ ]
Facebook I got [ __ ]
I got pumped because people started like
getting confused because paid was
underpriced and I was like I'm not
emotional if I can't like I get that
this was free but if this is still a
good deal then it's still a good deal I
don't care about yesterday back to that
mentality like yesterday doesn't matter
Facebook's free you got all that organic
traffic you weren't paying facebook for
that organic track it was a trade they
had a platform with a lot of attention
you produce the content for it and a
trade the organic goes down you have to
pay for it you have to do a lot more
paint the reason have to do a lot more
paid everybody is you can target who you
want to reach when you know you're about
to spend $150 against employees of your
direct competitor from eight towns over
you're already thinking differently in
the video you're about to make
you might make a video of like how fun
it is at your foosball table in your
office because Rick and the other
companies like we've all table click I
don't like I only make content knowing
who's gonna see it people like you
always come out I'm like I made a video
called you're 65 and your life's not
over and I ran ads against people who
are 65 it's gonna do well it's really
it's people underestimate how powerful
it is but if you make the podcast you'll
crush because now you're gonna have CEOs
and CFOs come in and be guests that's
gonna already be a slight bizdev
opportunity but you're also gonna be
able to post produce and run some of
those funny quotes funny moments you're
gonna be i she's gonna be looking you're
gonna be thinking oh he like Jason I are
doing it right now I'm like what I'm
telling you to do I'm doing right now
like as I'm talking I'm like looking I'm
like did you see that was that smart
should we cut that let's test that like
that's what you'll be doing in a year
and now all of a sudden you answered a
question where the CFO of the top 15
company like is really caught off guard
and she's like that's smart now you're
like oh you know now you're running it
against all CFO's the machine so you
were sort of the content
yes so for you and you want one library
we said a year and nobody watched it yes
so we're producing contact personal
brand and other things you didn't let
that sway me but the market you know
eventually because I have no
expectations of the market for a long
time I think I'm a showman in hindsight
something I didn't know about myself at
34 I really didn't like I never I got a
D in speech you know like like I didn't
know that I had this stick I know it was
a good salesman on the floor at the
liquor store I knew that I was a good
class clown where the teacher wasn't mad
at me so I knew I had a good tact but
none of this stuff even crossed my mind
so now I mean I think if I did anything
tomorrow it would work really if I
talked about something I knew like if I
need a sports I would need a number I
genuinely believe I'd be the number one
voice in sports today if I decided
tomorrow for the next three years to go
all-in I think I'd be bigger than Steven
Naismith and Max Kellerman and all these
guy just do because I think I have a
personality that clicks with people
that's just a trait
some people don't that's why I talk
about writing and audio you might not be
great on video but you might be a
tremendous writer or you might just not
be cracked up to be the personality then
you lean into the logo or hire somebody
MetLife hired Snoopy yeah you know so
that's where a piece of content where
you talks about how like you do this
thing a very invested oh the stairs you
know I think I'm uncomfortable with not
having some cash on hand for a rainy day
so I think I used to think a lot now I'm
old it a little bit from it but I'm a
very big fan of getting people to invest
in your business instead of taking the
money off the table like just everybody
wants to build big businesses but then
what they're really doing is building
lifestyle businesses for the things they
want which is also tough for me because
if you want a car look kudos do your
thing but yeah there I mean I
aggressively in the first five years of
Vayner and the first five years of Wine
Library had a pretty hardcore system
where like one year I would try to make
no profit porvis at all
zero a little bit more just for for for
both I'll give it to you for both
businesses between five and ten percent
is that where you run it today I keep
running it cuz I'm just like but again
I'm building it in perpetuity you have
to know what you're up to like again if
somebody here wants to flip their
business I like and I'm sure everybody's
big boy and big girl enough to know that
but yeah I mean like look it's it's it's
your other family member right you got
to feed it go take care of it you know
if you want to build big yeah which is
the goal well then you got to feed it
and then that's when you can fire and
fire like all that stuff because you're
not worried about the people like well
Gary it costs more to fire somebody well
I'm not as worried about the profit
margin being insane I'm trying to catch
the road
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]